you don't have to have a huge audience
you just have to have enough that come
in and buy at that level so right now we
operate on I believe like a $90 average
order value uh you could do the math in
your head right now it doesn't take a
lot of sales to get to 100 Grand per
month relatively uh when you're at $90
average per value uh versus with
something like AdSense most people are
getting between what is it like one and
$4 CPA is the the average that gets
thrown out in the industry that's a lot
of people you have to bring in to make
any kind of money at all yeah and it
sounds like you know I think for the
YouTube
mindset um is focused on I have to go
viral to make this sustainable and
what's also interesting was it at all a
struggle for you to have that view
differential I think for some if you
don't have a big visible view count
which could be arguably a vanity metric
it could hurt your ego it could make you
feel like you're not successful as a
YouTuber you're not getting Mr Beast
numbers even the lid or like the height
of your content won't compare to your
other channels numbers it's not as much
broad appeal right but it's such a it's
a much more effective business but was
that just easy for you because you saw
behind the scenes or was there any kind
of ego of like well I'm not pulling you
your most viewed video has six plus
million views or seven and you're you're
not pulling those numbers but it's such
a niche thing was it an easy transition
for you or is there anything I'll say
there's a slight bit of ego but I think
that I kind of worked through those ego
problems before I even went fulltime on
Thomas Frank explains yeah uh and the
reason for that is I had been in the
productivity Niche for so long I was
kind of the top of it for a while and
then Matt dll came along better ideas
came along Ali abdall came along and
even before they all passed me up I
could tell like they're going to pass me
up they're either hungrier or they make
better content in certain Dimensions or
they're publishing more often like I can
see the trajectory and I can either
chase that hamster wheel because I want
to satisfy my ego and stay on top or I
can really dig deep and say like like
what is it that I actually want to do
what what's the average day that I want
to experience what are the metrics that
actually matter I don't necessarily want
to be a famous person I don't want to be
mobbed when I go to a place like this um
so chasing the fame is actually
counterintuitive to what I want there's
like that Bill Murray story where he's
like I always tell people who want to be
rich and famous try being rich first see
if that covers all the bases uh and i'
I've definitely realize that like as
I've become a little bit less known
generally I'm actually happier I can go
more places not get recognized I can
spend more time on the highly technical
Niche things that actually interest me
and there's an audience there that is so
hungry for that kind of content as well
I can have a sustainable career without
needing to chase the big numbers two
things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free masterclass yet you're
going to love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
think masterclass.com for a 1-hour deep
dive on demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm going to go refill
my coffee hope to see you on the class